les cheminées de la fonderie horne sont
loin des mètres seulement de l'arsenic
dans l'air de rouyn noranda
en réalité selon les plus récentes
données fédérales l'entreprise rejette
au moins 23 contaminants du cadmium du
nickel du plomb par exemple et pour
plusieurs de ces substances la fonderie
est le plus grand pollueur au québec
parfois même au canada secteur jeunes
selon l'analyse que j'ai en fait c'est
pas parce que c'est une situation qui
perdure depuis de nombreuses années
qu'on devrait davantage l'accepter cette
spécialiste juge la liste inquiétante
d'autant plus que la science n'est pas
assez avancée pour déterminer
précisément l'effet combiné de ces
substances sur la santé humaine dit elle
mais plusieurs substances qui sont
cancérigènes grande inquiétude donc de
santé publique je remarque aussi dans
cette liste là plusieurs métaux
contaminants qui peuvent avoir un effet
sur le cerveau qui sont des contaminants
connu pour être neurotoxiques et ça ça
m'inquiète aussi parce que ce sont des
effets ciment qui vont donner un un peu
invisible qui ne voit pas à l'oeil nu
par courriel la fonderie horne soutient
que pour certaines substances dont
l'arsenic les données ont été surestimés
en raison d'une contamination de la
sonde utiliser l usine l'année dernière
n'empêche que les risques accrus de
cancer du poumon à rouyn noranda sont
désormais bien documenté et le
gouvernement continue d'improviser selon
la députée locale lorsqu'on a eu une
interpellation sur la question
j'ai lu est précisément poser des
questions est-ce qu'ils ont des données
pour savoir c'est quoi les effets
synergiques d'une exposition à plusieurs
métaux en simultané ministre était
incapable de me répondre le ministre de
l'environnement benoît charette négocie
actuellement avec la fonderie horne pour
la forcer à réduire ses émissions
d'arsenic mais devant la longue liste de
contaminants il se dit aussi ouvert à
imposer des cibles pour d'autres métaux
comme le réclament de plus en plus
d'acteurs dont la députée locale et la
mer est de rouyn noranda ici alexandre
duval radio canada québec